welcome back Todd hey Mark how you doing
I'm great so last time we did an
interesting talk about your work as a
correctional officer and we'll get into
some of that as well but let's talk
about you as a young man how you grew up
we didn't really get into that last time
okay where'd you grow up I grew up in
Philly but I moved to California when I
was nine Van Ice
where was your family like
uh well mom and dad started with my mom
and dad only siblings that I'm no
brothers and sisters of course they met
in Philly you have no siblings no my
parents don't have no siblings oh I see
Mom and Dad so they grew up bad my dad
was sent to military school at a young
age his parents didn't want him and then
my mom
did a lot of drugs in Philly So
eventually my dad and mom were off uh
dating each other when I was born and my
brother was born he's older than me by
two years and then eventually my Dad
decided let's pack up and go and move to
Van Nuys in 1979 to get away from all my
mom's uh drug habits and so forth did it
work and it didn't work so in 1979 we
moved the Van Nuys and basically she
continued
doing drugs off and on and I was nine so
you know I'm in elementary school coming
home and she's High mostly uh
prescription drugs and shooting up Coke
in her in her arms needle marks track
marks so at a young age
I was young and my brother
my brother uh he has a different
mindset of treating my mom a certain way
because he was older so more mature I
was younger so I didn't really uh I
didn't have anger issues with my mom and
my brother kind of uh wanted to protect
me not me seeing what my mom's going
through so he was kind of hiding a lot
of things and avoiding certain things to
me
and knowing that my mom's getting high
it also did something to me because I
can't bring friends over I had to go
walk in the house tell my friends hold
off for a minute make sure my mom wasn't
loaded when she wasn't loaded I'll bring
my friends over but if she was loaded I
want to bring my friends over because I
was embarrassed she was learning words
smoking cigarettes [__] almost
burning the house down slurring or you
know just when somebody's loaded off of
prescription drugs
[__] up and she's doing shooting up so
my dad's working all day and then my dad
would come home he would know that my
mom's High he'd be looking for the
prescription drugs you know the volumes
up uppers and downers and all that other
[__] she was doing so that continued for
a long time so my childhood to me was
real bad and then it got to a point
graduated elementary school and then
started junior high and then my dad
started using and then one and basically
trying to do this in chronological order
there's so much layers of [__] that
happened in my life but I'm gonna try to
speed it up and try to do it in order so
then Junior High me and my brother are
walking home managers out front and the
managers crying and we're like oh
something happened and basically she
says that your dad uh your dad went to
jail so we walk in the apartment and our
apartment was thrashed my dad was uh
selling so LAPD was doing a sting and
they watched him I guess for a while as
he was selling we didn't know he was
selling of course and they [__]
destroyed our apartment and that a
search warrant and back then in the 80s
they [__] up the house like cereal
boxes turned over [__] uh pillows
everything in the pillows [__] up and
meanwhile we have no family so me and my
brother walk in the house
only thing we can do is start cleaning
up the house my Mamas are I don't know
if my mom my mom wasn't living with us
course and I don't know if my mom was in
rehab or I don't know if my mom was
locked up too because they weren't
together at that point so me and my
brother we had no choice start cleaning
up the house and whatever whatever and
go to school the next day so we cleaned
the house until like one in the morning
your whole
was that uh I was uh in seventh grade
that makes me 13 or 14 I think
my brother was a ninth so uh
cleaned up the house got down to like
one in the morning and my dad called us
three days later in jail
and basically he had a plead public
defender he had to plead a felon or he
was gonna go get locked up for a while
so he played he was a felon so that
stuck with him for a long time and he
got out and uh basically that was
seventh grade meanwhile during seventh
grade I'm working in the summer uh we're
on food stamps free cheese and kind of
embarrassing because we had no money man
that's how we're living over there Top
Ramen cup of noodles
and basically uh kind of running the
streets you know friends were our family
like I said we didn't have uncles we'd
have aunts grandfathers grandmothers all
that [__] we didn't have nobody
so then uh right around that time
my mom's dad owned a bar in Philly and
he got shot in the face in Philly dude
walks in and mumbles something he was on
drugs and he shoots my grandfather
inside of his own bar and my my
grandfather died and basically my mom
went back to Philly
and me and my brother couldn't go back
to Philly because they had no money to
pay for us to go back to the funeral
so I don't know how I tell my dad like
how did you guys not find a way to get
money to send us back to Philly for her
[__] funeral that cost four or five
hundred but back then we was poverty
like didn't have gofundme's and all that
other [__] credit he didn't have credit
so
anyway never went to the funeral
um grandfather got murdered and uh that
was right around that time too
and then
um
trying to figure out the [__]
timeline here so Dad gets out of jail
going through the motions and then
um speed during that time hanging out
with my buddies uh playing a lot of
basketball we lived across the street
from elementary school and basically our
friends were our family back then
because there's nobody else to turn to
but uh no [__] prom no grad night no
money for none of that [__] collecting
cans making money knocking door to door
in the summertime trying to wash cars
some candy door to door I don't know if
I just said that some flowers on the
[__] corner just uh cold call in
uh cold calling you know when you read
something you call people and try to
sell [__] did that for a quick minute
just trying to make money man and then
this is all during the summertime and
then sandblasting Auto Parts 335 an hour
dick construction five bucks an hour
digging footings and doing blocks in the
summertime we knew people lived in an
apartment that needed help so we're just
grinding man so then uh basically ninth
grade
graduated Junior High
and uh
same [__] running the streets lived in
the valley
chasing girls you know hormones are
kicking in
and then um
let's see
what else uh I'm trying to figure out if
right around ninth grade uh my dad
starts using again and then he gets over
there hit over the head with a bottle
and uh he's in the hospital he's got a
big ass scar around his head and uh
basically they jumped him I think in
Panorama City
and my dad
was in the hospital for a while and then
uh he got out and then Mom started using
hardcore
and then eventually mom overdosed
and we had no money and I was working
I was 18 at the time and I'm working
your mom passed away passed away
overdosed yup same thing your whole uh
18. 18 at the time and then um we had no
money my brother was working part-time
going to school
and then I was working full-time so I'm
the one that had the money so I had to
use my own money to bury my mom
and then um
just had to keep on working and grinding
and you graduated high school graduated
high school but nobody called how you
guys doing checking up on us no other
family members so it's like
never mourned really man you just got to
keep on going because that's how it is
we don't know no different it's a rough
childhood
definitely rough childhood so during
that time 18
cruising
San Fernando cruising Whittier cruising
Crenshaw
so now I'm cruising now I got money to
buy clothes now I'm going clubbing I'm
all over the place man we're going to
Tijuana we're going to Ensenada Rosarito
and I've always been confident about
basically
since I grew up like that and don't make
excuses
I have something in me two things I
don't give a [__] what people think
about me and I'm gonna keep on living my
life
and
basically no excuses and I'm gonna think
I'm better than everybody else that had
a normal childhood sorry you're angry at
your mom
no I wasn't angry my brother was angry
but I wasn't angry because I was younger
and I just give her kind of hall pass
she never treated me mean and I knew she
had a drug problem
so anybody that has a drug problem I'm
not going to talk [__] and say you're
dumb as [__] blah blah blah because at
the end of the day it's your DNA gene
pool and addictive personality and you
got no control over that [__] the object
is since I know that that's why I never
dipped into drugs because I'll be a
monster if I was on drugs with my
personality I got other issues if it's
gaining weight losing weight doing [__]
like that that I go to the extreme but
drugs that's one thing I knew like yeah
I'm gonna go 120 balls deep into it so
you still seeing based on the way you
speak pretty intense
I've always had an edge to me like fight
or flight mentality I had to
so like I said I built that up
my whole life if it's playing sports if
I get on the basketball court back in
the day and I'm playing ball
this dude I'm thinking this guy had a
mom and dad he probably went to summer
camp and I'm better than him and I grew
up rougher so I got more heart than you
and I got more will than you and I'm
gonna [__] reset you know I'm
resentless I'm [__] Relentless you
know what I mean resentless that's why I
look at it they're a lot less
yeah so that's my mentality
so I'm gonna outwork you and I'm an
outdo ya because I've been through his
[__] hell and back and another thing
is during that time growing up when my
mom did pass I had to kind of live a
straight life thinking that my mom was
always watching me
and I don't want to disappoint her so
that's another thing trying to live a
straight life like oh I can't do that I
don't disappoint my mom
if you believe in spirituality and all
that you know also older brother that
helps big time because that's like an
angel right here when I'm about to do
something stupid my brother's right
there going
don't be doing that [__] so I'm thinking
about those things too as I'm doing
stuff
so that kind of help having an older
sibling and I think being a younger
sibling than him that helped him also
we're not twins but for some reason we
have that Bond you look up to your
brother yeah we're [__] I have a dad
and then I have my brother but my
brother is my dad I'm going to my
brother before I'm going to my dad how
much older almost two years
so successful graduated college same
thing used to ride his bike to work
so to me both of us we're successful
knowing the way we grew up we could
easily come on man eight out of ten
people that grew up the way we did
they're living a [__] up life they're
drug addicts they're in jail or they're
dead
so to me we won we're under doves and we
won
that's the way I look at it so I went
every day
I might be on borrowed time the way I
live my life back in the day but my
attitude is kind of YOLO you only live
once live to the fullest but don't do
nothing stupid to kill yourself
so that's my mentality
so uh anyway growing up the way I grew
up that's where different ethnic
backgrounds kicked in
cruising Crenshaw mostly
African-American
we didn't care me and my buddies didn't
care we had nice cars we had nice sound
systems we went into all kinds of
different music Cruise in Whittier
mostly Hispanics same thing
go into Mr Jay's El Monte going to
Century Club so going to all these
different clubs that are diverse walk in
didn't even care if I'm the only white
guy in a African-American Club I didn't
care I love the music I love the culture
and I'm gonna have fun same thing being
in a Hispanic culture if I'm going to a
Whittier I'm going clubbing out there
towards uh La Puente or whatever and I'm
only white guy I'm gonna blend right in
because I like the music I'm into all
kinds of music Lisa Lisa Cult Jam I'm
into uh Stevie B or I'm into Barry White
Isaac Hayes we can go back to anything
Keith Sweat you get along with all the
other I get along with everybody
because to me I'm kind of unique where
I'm natural about a lot of things man I
used to record off of KDAY KDAY was a
popular uh uh basically radio station
back in the day in the 80s man when raps
started bumping and they used to have uh
on Saturday nights they used to have DJs
and all that and had a boom box and I
used to record
on the Boombox set out the door cassette
I'd go to Tower Records buy my uh my
blank cassettes and I would sit there on
a Saturday and I'll record and I knew in
a half an hour come back flip the other
side and record so I used to do that I
was a break dancer I was a popper so I
was into that culture man Low Rider car
like I said I was into all that still
into all of it that's being unique
growing up in the 80s
so anyway that kind of helped my job
being a CEO we'll get to that in a
minute so anyway living that lifestyle
hanging around all kinds of people that
are different races playing sports
watching sports love music so to me I
was cool growing up even though
we were poor
going to the uh Supermarket we're on
food stamps and there's five or six
people behind us and then my dad
whipping out food stamps and the old
food stamps had uh you know five dollars
ten dollars twenty dollars and my dad's
ripping it and we have our groceries and
then my dad's telling the person that's
ringing up the groceries uh how much is
it right now 110 uh take this back do
that scan this how much is that and
everybody's staring at us and my dad's
playing with food stamps so you're kind
of feeling shameful like man these
people are looking at us but for some
reason I kind of use it as just
motivation like
not that we're freeloading not that
we're poor like I didn't care what
people thought man what do you think it
is that
allowed you and your brother to be
survivors and not not fall into the
traps that they having each other
by luck
gotta be luck too man
just like you driving home from work or
me driving home from work not getting in
a car accident somebody not running
through a red light that's luck man
imagine you know people are dying 10
seconds after we're leaving this place
or that place you know shooting whatever
whatever
it's just luck and maybe uh
knowing that there's going to be
consequences man if you [__] up like
that if you have a record job wise
and I don't want to do that man we've
done a lot of [__] you're married
yeah I'm married how long you been
married
uh over 20 been with her over 30.
but being younger man yeah I got two
kids that I know of I probably got more
out there man and they're over 18 so I'm
cool
you uh
you became a CEO into the marriage right
seal in a marriage but I was a mailman
when I first met her so I was running
the post office so she had to deal with
you and all the crap you would bring
home from the CEO job
yeah but I left that alone that's not
something you come home and talk about
being a cop
how was your day honey
you really want to know how my day was I
don't want to freak her out
all day was great I saw like 150
[__] today because we had to make
them bend over and cough
no we're good
so
but I was a mailman that was a good job
right out of high school civil service
in order to get to take a test it had
401k and it benefits so when I met her I
was already a mailman so I anyway I did
the mailman thing 15 years out of high
school
so I did that
and that was good great experience
I've always been a person to ask
questions to older people and learn from
the older people
and suck up
all that information
you know what I mean
if you're home and I'm delivering mail
to you and you got an RV and you got a
Harley Davidson I'm gonna ask questions
man how much was there Harley did you
pay cash
how much was your RV can you finance
that what's this mean what's people that
are successful I want that when I was
younger and I still I'm still the same
way I'm a sponge man I want to observe
as much absorb as much knowledge as
possible I learned every day from other
people that's the only way you're going
to learn
you know what I mean you got to ask
questions you got to ask do research I
don't think I know everything
where the younger generation is a little
different
you enjoy your years as a CEO
CEO was cool doing it I loved it at
first and then eventually the way the uh
uh politics are
living in California
it's kind of like a revolving door where
you can't make a difference I want to
make a difference
and to me
I think I made a difference
because these guys are kind of similar
backgrounds
like me
so it's kind of like when I'm talking to
these dudes
it's kind of like a friendship you got
to talk to these dudes some people some
CEOs don't talk to them and interact
they want nothing to do with these dudes
they hate their guts [__] [__] them
that kind of attitude I mean I was
different
I could sit there and talk to [__]
five inmates for hours about life about
anything you want
but I'm cool with that because you gotta
you gotta do that imagine going to work
all day angry and you hate somebody
how the [__] do you get away with that
all day and then come home and turn that
off you can so when I went to work it
was fun man talking [__] they're talking
[__] and we're having fun
sometimes of course it goes down
one-on-one or whatever you're not going
to be friends with everybody
just like you had uh when you're in
junior high or high school there's some
people you didn't know but right away
you didn't like them they thought they
were cool too cool they're trying to act
hard just like prison you have some guys
that you don't even like and you don't
even know them they just come off the
wrong way even your partners that you
work with you don't like them same [__]
that's the hardest
imagine working eight hours with
somebody that's totally different than
you
and you got to work with somebody that's
even harder man so dealing with
personalities on the job that's the
hardest man
I'm running a building I got 10 years in
and here's a guy that's working with me
for eight hours that's younger and this
dude's coming in my building my partner
and he's trying to run [__]
whoa whoa whoa whoa
go back in the office bro I'm running
this [__] this is my building try to
[__] try to take over this and that
so yeah man personalities have the job
got these young kids coming out of the
academy 24 25 trying to [__] swole up
trying to act like they're hard no man
it's different approach
gotta talk
so to me talking with these guys it was
cool it was an easy job
I could defuse a lot of situations just
by humidity
de-escalating yeah it makes perfect
sense and it's like that in life
sometimes you try to de-escalate and of
course you can because that person's not
letting you de-escalate but majority of
the time
relax tone that [__] down come on man
let's go over here and talk
bring that race over here bringing that
race they're called Mac reps let's talk
bro what's what's going on man what
about if we do this do that so yeah
you're talking you're communicating [__]
runs good I want my buildings when I ran
it to be nice and clean and run smooth
man
but I know one thing when I'm working
you guys can't be [__]
acting crazy when my captains or
lieutenants come walking through I want
I wanted this building to run nice and
smooth man where I kind of have it under
control not like you guys are walking on
me so it's kind of like a game too also
man
but when you're at Academy you're
gung-ho
you're trying to [__] write these
dudes up for anything just to keep them
locked up forever and then after that
after you do that notice knowing that
sometimes the captains don't give them
extra time then you start like oh man
this system's all [__] up you're going
out of your way to write reports all day
long and nothing's happening to these
guys
so
that's kind of a bad situation too
last time you shared a couple of your
stories about your time at the prisons
but uh
I'm sure you've got more
oh I got plenty man
tell me a story or two about some of the
Saul things you went through
I got a buddy of mine that worked in
Lancaster married kids and he
transferred to a female prison
worked uh First Watch 10 o'clock at
night
six in the morning
and started banging one of the female
inmates long story short brings in a
phone
still banging her she has the phone on
he's on top of her and she's saying get
off me
he's still [__]
then eventually
she sets him up
so now he's in prison for rape
she set him up
when uh inmate does that kind of stuff
to a guard
they're kind of like uh real popular
knowing that they broke down a guard and
manipulated even in the guy's prison
same thing if a guy breaks down a female
guard or female staff and that staff is
bringing in dope and all that that
dude's like a cool inmate now you know
what I mean just like these dudes
getting out of prison because they
escaped because they broke down a female
like think about that
think about a female
or a male bringing in [__] to help a
inmate escape
like think about what that how that can
even
go down
it's crazy
are all the prisoners that are in the
prisons you worked in
would you say that pretty much all of
them are up to some kind of hustle or
some kind of something Shady not all of
them there's some that are never gonna
yeah I'm never I'm never gonna say all
of them I'm never going to say any all
every race
I'm it all depends on how much time
they're serving depends on their age
depends if they want to get out or not
so it's not going to be all of them but
majority of them
are trying to hustle to make their lives
better
in prison imagine if you're locked up in
prison with no phone and imagine getting
a phone how much life would be so much
easier
having a [__] phone like think about
that or drugs imagine being on drugs
when you're doing time think about how
many days and weeks go by when you're
loaded
think about what that does to your brain
knowing your hustle mentality trying to
break down people and do certain things
so I'm not going to never say all of
them just like this
is every inmate guilty is there innocent
inmates in prison yeah there's there's
innocent people that are probably in
prison right now I would never say no
man they're 100 guilty no man
it's human life human error there's good
and bad in every race there's good and
bad in every profession
so I'm not going to say everybody's
guilty
but
majority of them you're guilty of doing
something
if you really want to be clean in prison
you can go to school you can get uh
degrees in school you can get
certificates and
you can live not live a good life but
you can uh prepare yourself
when you get out
to be successful
and I like the underdog roll so I would
never say I want all these [__]
to fail and I no man guys that get out
and do good
bro I'm down man because that would be
my mentality
what's the word recidivism recidivism
right yep that's it 70 go back in so
think about that the ones that get out
and don't go back in bro that's [__]
good [__] but like we were talking the
first episode it's hard not to go back
in because the environment they live in
the tools who is the darkest craziest
person you you saw there
in prison
darker what do you mean I mean just
who's the most evil guy you've ran
across uh
this guy was I was in an ambulance and
we're taking him to the hospital and he
was strapped down he had a spit mask on
and this dude was [__] mentally crazy
and I'm back there with another partner
and then uh EMTs are you know [__]
trying to talk to him and [__] write
down notes and I'm right next to this
dude and he's looking at me and he's
just [__] raging and I'm thinking if
somehow some way this dude gets out of
those [__] restraints
I don't know man my little [__]
pepper spray might not do nothing
so yeah man I was scared like the
mentally ill guys are the ones that
or crazy as [__] you don't know what
you're dealing with other guys you can
talk to and
have a rapport but you're talking about
mental health-wise [__] man talk about
guys that are [__] weighing maybe a
buck 60 they got [__] strength for
days I've seen those kind of guys take
on five or six guards man pepper sprayed
pepper spray doesn't even affect these
[__]
they're like what the [__] so yeah man
mental health is a big deal in prison
and I don't know if prisons the right
place for them man
maybe they should be in a mental
hospital you know what I mean
and it's sad but
I don't think they were born like that
maybe their trauma growing up maybe
their drug use so that kind of maybe
[__] them up too man years of that
you know but I would never judge and say
I would never do this and that if I was
locked up in prison I don't know how I
would be so I can say I would be
different than them
so we're the first episode we're talking
about you know homosexuals and all that
I don't know if I would be a homosexual
in there if I'm doing life and never
getting out
I might be the [__] biggest booty
bandit in there I might take everybody's
ass I don't give a [__] Nobody's Gonna
Know
so
salute to R Kelly because ours Kelly is
in prison right now and I know he's
tearing [__] up right now knowing the
[__] that he's into
R Kelly's a bottom or a top he's putting
work in right now Mark
uh what else
working First Watch
dude's real skinny flexible by himself
bottom bunk
the mattress is rolled up
keys are in my pocket out of the academy
do my [__] check
dudes give himself a [__]
so I was like wow
sickening but maybe not imagine if we
can give ourselves blow jobs it'd be
kind of unique and funny you saw that
saw that [__] yeah this dude was going
to town sucking his own you know what
yeah so that's crazy [__]
but
maybe if I was flexible I'd be doing it
too who knows
hold on man tell my buddies hold on I'll
be out in a minute give myself a [__]
um what else man
guy uh Lancaster
over 10 years in tons of overtime Works
visiting
Finance [__] goes to visiting gets her
phone number starts banging her outside
of work eventually she says
you're not supposed to be banging
inmates sisters or family members blah
blah blah you know you get fired for
that long story short
the chick was a sister of her brother in
the same building
had him all scared starts bringing in
phones starts bringing in dope so
basically she set him up eventually got
popped
threw it all away making over 100 G's a
year working a bunch of overtime
boats Harleys jet skis
living a good life man working hard
eventually he got caught up he got fired
like I said we're all human man
so how do you see the difference between
the good guys and the bad the guys that
are in prison and the cops or the CEOs
yeah they're CEOs that are [__] just
as bad as pie inmates just never got
caught
that's my big thing when I was talking
to inmates
you [__] think you're crazy
I'm crazy too and I've done more [__]
than you
I just never got caught
so I've done a lot of [__] don't think
I'm a square
I've done a lot of [__]
but you could tell the ones that are
[__] just crazy don't give a [__]
because nobody cared about them
and they're just ruthless man
and I got some of that in me
just didn't grow up maybe in that same
environment all the way maybe those
dudes didn't have a brother
maybe those dudes didn't have the
concept of somebody passing away going I
don't want to disappoint you
maybe they never had that where I had
that where it kind of helped me back a
little bit and they just went full on
throttle doing crazy ass [__] with their
boys if you had that mentality and you
hang around four or five friends and
they have that mentality huh you guys
are going to be out of control so
that's the thing
Mass murderers in there serial killers
um
there's everybody in there man I started
reading the C files C files are what
they're in there for so I used to work
uh First Watch 10 o'clock at night six
in the morning
and I would work a regular building
maybe on overtime I would have a report
with these dudes so I'd write down their
CDC number they got a letter and then
they got like six digits I think and
then I'll write that down and I'll just
go [__] what this guy's in what's this
guy in here for and that would go you
know and read their C files and you're
reading and you're like [__] man
crazy what this guy did at this age and
just stacks of [__] that they've done so
you start reading those C files and that
shit's crazy but then also that will
make you change the way you talk to them
if you know what they're actually in
there for so I stopped doing that
if I had a good report with somebody you
know somebody was real respectful yes
sir this and that and then you find out
that they were they killed a bunch of
people and all that how can you really
look at them in the face and really
treat them the same so I stopped doing
that C file [__]
had a guy in uh Lancaster
uh basically rape a young girl at the
movie theater and he was in my building
and he was the biggest [__] [__]
banging on the door I got a headache I
got chest pains I need to go to the
[__] infirmary and then I found out
what this guy's in here for and right
away like once I found out what he's in
there for I didn't give him [__]
so yeah man
but yeah you can read him on the
internet he had a girl [__] naked in
the movie theater out there in the
Antelope Valley [__] molester he was
in my building
we had another guy in uh Lancaster
Oxnard uh a gay kid was coming out to
him in school you bring a gun to school
and he killed him in the classroom he
had a documentary on HBO I think or
Showtime
so he got there like right when he
turned 21. no tattoos or nothing and by
the time I left and retired he was a
full-on [__]
down with the [__]
uh White Boys in there
all tatted up and [__] it young I'm not
getting out it's all down now it's I'm
riding a dieting writing riding and
dying for his race that's what happens
Young Generation
they're all in which race tends to
dominate most in in prison
so reynos Hispanics and whites
because they got that in there really
not going to say one race is more
there's more of one race
I'm Gonna Keep It
100 where just say there's a bunch of
blacks in there there's a bunch of
Hispanics there's a bunch of whites but
I think the whites and Hispanics are
more organized and that's why they
dominate
running
the drugs and running all this [__] in
there the reason that the race has
become such a big thing in the prison is
because they just need to they have in
their blood to fight and they just want
to separate they want to find a reason
to separate
um that's against them well it's
politics and the money like
you got to kind of choose a side which
side you want to be on when you're in
there
I'm white I gotta roll with the whites
if you're Asian you're considered other
Samoans other
Armenians are there
and then they're called Pisces Border
Brothers
they're kind of separate
a lot of them up North but they're kind
of they blend in with the sereno's
undercover
and those other ones Fresno Bulldogs up
north separate
they're separate man so the gang's on
the street and the gangs in prison are
different but a guy who ends up going to
prison for
bank fraud and he's not really a gang
member he's not really a thug he's just
somebody who got I don't think he'll be
in there for State that'll be probably
Federal Federal Prison
so you didn't see that no I don't think
I don't think uh like bank robbers and
[__] like that I don't think they do
stay time
I think they do all federal time
domestic uh murders child molesters
that's all state so
but yeah so thank God it's like that man
because I think I said that before how
they if they all got together and
focused on us and they all United [__]
that'd be a dangerous situation in there
so thank God they are different in the
politics kick in and that you know
they're into their own [__] making money
and surviving
better life in there if you
if you have money in there money's
everything in there
um manipulation all day long man if it's
the manipulate family members by calling
rain letters trying to get more money on
their books
that goes down all day long conjugal
visits we're part of uh conjugal visits
they had them in Lancaster and they had
them in Soledad yeah basically if you're
not a lifer or level four I think you
can get visits I think it's like Friday
to Sunday so they would come in and
basically bring a bunch of food and then
you have these like uh
uh like not dorms like little houses on
grounds
in Italy man
[__] Boneyard
it's got to be born in all weekend
we'd have to go like three times a day
to do count
knock on the door and they would have to
read off their last name and read off
their CDC number make sure that they're
in there and they're allowed to visit
with their
spouses or girlfriends or whatever you
know for how long
Friday to Monday I think Friday to
Sunday so a long time or Saturday to
Sunday oh yeah [__] [__] imagine
eight hours with just them that makes
prison almost tolerable
fuck-a-thon man eight hours of
being with a female oh yeah
um are there prisoners who you saw
developed relationships with females
outside the oh yeah prison Oh you mean
with staff no with staff or even better
yet with just women that are fascinated
with these guys oh yeah yeah definitely
man yeah that's fascinating to me
[__] [__] I think Richard Ramirez The
Night Stalker I think he married his
lawyer
Scott Peterson yeah all these dudes man
these guys get tons of letters from
females on the outside that love these
dudes yeah man like crazy I'd love to
interview some of those the women the
women oh
I probably listen to it for five minutes
and shut it off because then we got to
be dumb as [__]
how can you marry how can you marry a
person that killed somebody that's never
getting out
what kind of relationship is that I
don't get it but that's yeah try to find
no try to find them man
see what's going on in their brain
uh like the Menendez brothers they were
uh they were up north at Mule Creek when
I was out of Academy
saw them at Mule Creek Suge Knight he
was at Mill Creek mule Creek's like s
and why those are high profile inmates
that were there maybe uh xcos maybe
government officials so that's like a
high-end uh prison where a lot of famous
uh
inmates are at I know Charles Manson was
at Corcoran Sirhan Sirhan was that Court
grin
but yeah the Menendez brothers
they were at Mill Creek Suge Knight
um let me see who else man Lancaster
told you before El DeBarge football
player
Lawrence Phillips
played for the Rams played for Nebraska
played for the Niners talked to him all
the time man
um
and he ended up he ended up killing
himself
yeah
I think current prison you ever get
friendly with anybody like actually
develop their own friendships with
anything
really yeah Lawrence Phillips like I
treated him good man because he treated
me good
he wasn't you know
level four you're not supposed to really
acknowledge the CEOs
so I'd be in culinary
that dude called me by my last name in
front of all the inmates
and we'd you know he would say oh what's
up did you watch uh the Lakers or
whatever I'm not a Laker fan so I'll say
[__] the Lakers and me and him are you
know which that's all we do is talk
about sports
but you know he'd brag about you know
watch the Lakers last night I'll [__]
the Lakers so we'd have a good
relationship talking about sports man
he was surprised how much I knew about
sports
and he killed himself
killed himself people don't think he
killed himself he killed himself killed
his cellmate up there
Kern Valley Bakersfield
um
sad situation man
but I had a good report right now man
we'd be on lockdown I would let that
dude out let him go to the yard I'll
call my buddy up that runs the tower on
the yard nobody would be out it'd be out
full on lockdown and I'll call my buddy
up hey man I'm gonna have uh Phillips
come out and work out
and I'll let him out for two hours man
go work out
Phillips didn't get along with other
inmates he's not part of the politics he
just wanted him running his own program
Lancaster we made him single cell where
he can never have a cellmate because he
went through like two or three cell
mates where he beat the [__] out of him
if he gave him uh gave him my soulmate
so he don't want to sell mate he's not
down to get woken up by a [__] cell
mate so when he got transferred to Kern
Valley
they sell them up at another inmate
so I don't know what happened in the
cell but he choked him out
you familiar with Lawrence Phillips or
no no
she was a beast man in college could
have been probably one of the best
running backs ever
he's going down as like one of the
biggest busts ever in Pros got drafted
first round by the Rams sixth seventh
pick first round
two was like playing against kids and uh
looked like he was playing against kids
in college he ended up in prison for
what uh domestic ran over some kids down
in L.A he had a bunch of things they
kind of piggybacked on
he'd have money public defender
yeah it was bad it was good it started
when he was in Nebraska he threw his
girl down some stairs in Nebraska
because this girl was cheating on him
with another teammate she was a
volleyball star and he threw her down
some stairs he got suspended so he had
kind of some anger issues growing up so
it started when he was at Nebraska
and it kind of continued
but yeah man we talked for hours man a
lot
I would hook them up extra phone calls
this that extra perks man people are
good to me I give you extra perks
there's no reason to make you suffer
you treat me good I'll treat you good
it's all good man you know what I mean
everybody wins
not no hard ass with everybody can't be
a hard ass with everybody what do you
think the secret is to being a CEO
communication
back in the day by communication to me
nothing [__] rah-rah [__] fighting
Gladiators style back in the whatever
70s or 80s and went down
as they hear stories from the older
guards or older inmates how it changed
the department but they used to [__]
throw down man guards would throw down
with inmates
but now that's different now they got
cameras in there
I think the guards are wearing body cams
now
so that [__] ain't going down no more
how often would things go down in the
yard that we're just out of control
once in a while all things go down it's
not every day
once in a while it goes down man nothing
you can do
somebody
rips off another race over or whatever
drug dead and that race doesn't
discipline them or
just whatever man dumb [__] it'll go off
and the riots would be caused by what
caused caused by what what would cause a
riot in the prison what I just said
One race not disciplining their own
and then it has to go down disrespecting
disrespecting is a big thing in there
so yeah man you got that many people in
that prison it can go down real quick
and it goes down it's crazy
but there's nothing we can really do to
run in there we're outnumbered so we
kind of got to wait to de-escalates and
then wait till we have more numbers and
then we go in there
and do what we got to do to de-escalate
it but yeah man when these dudes got to
do something and they're told to do it
they got to do it
how many murders did you see well you
were a guard
um seen a few
but overdose I've seen one well I was on
Hospital coverage where the dude came
back from a visit and he uh
he fell out passed out whatever he
swallowed a balloon and the balloon blew
up in his uh stomach
and then I did the hospital where he was
basically
on a machine dead already
and they just had to declare him dead
um
other
murders guys fighting just getting
stabbed but
not dying in front of me never really
saw nobody die in front of me
um
but it happens but it's not like every
day it's not like every week where
people are dying you know what I mean
but when you get told to do something
these guys got to do it but they ever
see prisoners just rehabilitate
themselves just because they had no
other option
they just made the best of themselves oh
definitely the older people the older
people got disciplined
yeah man there's they'll stay in their
cells they'll read a lot
Yeah man they won't get you won't even
notice that they're in there because
they're just
keep a low profile
they don't want to be seen man they do
their own program so it's possible like
I said
but if you're a rah-rah kind of guy and
you want to be a follower and you got a
lot of buddies in there you definitely
get influence man
uh what else man
guys uh get rushed to the hospital
they'll stick uh phones up their ass
they'll stick a shank up their ass
that [__] happens too man
stomach pain take him to the infirmary
do an x-ray all of a sudden man they got
something to travel they stuck something
up too far and they got [__] just you
know what is it a lot disloded or
whatever inside of them so they got to
go out and go to surgery
they get told they got to do this and
that they're doing it they're smuggling
it so that goes down a lot
um not all of them of course but the
ones that are trying to fit in and make
a name for themselves they gotta start
at the bottom see if they're down or not
just like
if one of their own finds out their uh
child molester they gotta [__] take
that person out like you told me last
time you never really shared a lot of
you never brought this stuff home to
your wife no never yeah I don't want to
freak her out you'd share with you other
other friends guards guards and get it
out of your system and take it home yeah
kids didn't even know about this [__]
that I'm telling right now so a lot of a
lot of stuff right now I'm telling this
is gonna be the first step my wife's
heard of it my brother's heard of it my
friends heard of it yeah good for you
and what I talked about my childhood my
kids don't know about that probably save
your marriage and your
kids didn't have to go through it yeah
man I try to and I still try to talk to
young people man about it got a
mentorship man gotta give back so I look
at it if I can get back a little bit to
other people out here on the street and
make a difference
I think I should I lived through it
so yeah man I'm big on that I'm big on
trying to help people out man
like I said I'm not cocky I'm confident
and it is what it is about going through
[__] in life I can't curl up in the
fetal position [__] suck my thumb
lock myself in bed and [__] be
depressed I ain't going out like that
so
probably still inside me a lot of [__]
but it is what it is what can I do
there's other people that are in worse
situations than me and been through
worse than me so I'm not going to say my
situation is the worst ever somebody
worse than me
but
I survived it I live a good life
keep on moving forward man that's all he
can do can't dwell on the pass man
something happened 20 years ago how's
that going to affect me tomorrow it's
not
but I love talking to kids man and
helping kids out you know what I mean
because our future man and they're lost
Young Generation is lost man with the
cell phone
Instagram Tick Tock I want to be a
YouTuber I want to be a millionaire
nah man it's one percent
stay in school go to school get an
education
and be good to society
respect our elders That's it man work
hard
appreciate the little things man
that's what life's all about especially
as you get older
gotta gotta enjoy life man if I'm going
to a sushi tonight it's a big thing for
me
you know what I mean so that's what I do
Top Ramen and [__] cup of noodles
came a long ways man
roaches in the apartment
yeah man all bad living
in Van Nuys man in those apartments
[__]
that's a big thing man where I was and
where I'm at
big difference man so I'm just gonna
keep on going forward
got a nice house got a brand new
Corvette should be living the way I live
good fear
all right Todd thanks Mark appreciate it
great seeing you again likewise man
thank you man yep